[Musique]
m
alger les étudiants européens ont pris
au marché la place des marchands
musulmans ceux ci comme les ouvriers du
service de nettoiement nous déserté la
ville européenne un attentat du centre
d'un bouche des dockers qui fit 62 morts
et 110 blessés tous musulmans
[Musique]
ainsi chaque jour mesure-t-on davantage
les graves conséquences de la violence
entretenue par l'ouest ça plus
spectaculaires manifestations ces
derniers jours aura été l'explosion du
camion-citerne piégée dans le quartier
des tagarins les sens la citerne en
contenait 16 mip propage à l' incendie
tout au long de l'avenue bilan trois
morts et une trentaine de blessés mais
le bilan aurait dû être plus tragique si
comme l'envisageait les auteurs de
l'attentât le camion avait achevé sa
course sur le quartier musulman bâti en
contrebas
et la fièvre d'alger s'alimente chaque
jour un peu plus à ces attentats qui
s'aiment systématiquement la terreur est
aussi l'arrêt
jusqu'ici les musulmans n'ont pas
répondu mais ils désertent les hôpitaux
habituel
acclimate france et dans d'autres
quartiers musulmans le fln a installé
ses propres hôpitaux les blessés
musulmans viennent chercher les soins
des médecins musulmans et dit on aussi
de médecins européens
le fossé on le voit n'est peut-être pas
si définitif
[Musique]
amsterdam pour la célébration de leurs
noces d'argent la reine juliana et le
prince bernhard ont conduit le cortège
des rois et des princes la reine
elizabeth au bras du shah d'iran
l'impératrice farah au bras du prince
ashwin de l'ip frère du prince bernhard
la princesse beatrix au bras du roi olav
de norvège la grande duchesse de
luxembourg au bras du prince philip
d'edimbourg 4 rennes st croix et des
dizaines de princes et de princesses qui
ont permis aux photographes de réaliser
un très exceptionnel portrait de famille
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que le land qui fut bien
entendu associé à cette fête qui
coïncidait avec la célébration du 53ème
anniversaire de la reine juliana a
célébré à sa manière le 1er mai un
premier mais royal
c'est une espèce de rencontre au sommet
idéal qui a réuni à washington john
glenn celui qui fit trois fois le tour
de la terre et d'hermann titeuf celui
qui le fit 17 fois ils ont considéré en
connaisseur la capsule qui transporta
shepard et se sont racontés bien entendu
des histoires d'astronautes
ensemble ils ont été reçus à la maison
blanche par le président kennedy n'ai
aucune révélation marquante une est
sorti de la confrontation des deux
cosmonautes
[Musique]
l'opéra de paris des centenaires ou
presque voici juste cent ans que fut
posée la première pierre d'une vingtaine
de projets qui avaient été soumis au
concours et qui proposait des monuments
très différents c'est le projet de
l'architecte charles garnier qui avait
été adoptée à l'unanimité d'ailleurs
garnier devait consacrer 14 ans à sa
réalisation les travaux qui allaient
permettre d'installer l'opéra de paris
dans sa 12ème salle celle qui serait du
reste la plus vaste du monde devait
durer jusqu en 1874 ont pu cependant
assisté en 1869 à la pause du célèbre
groupe de carpeaux la danse est garni
avait été en mesure d'offrir de 1867 au
parisien la façade de son monument qui
s'inscrivait dans le cadre des travaux
du baron haussmann
enfin en 1875 la république inaugurait
l'oeuvre de l' empire mais c'est le pari
de 1862 celui qui célèbrait au grand
hôtel en présence de l'impératrice
eugénie la pose de la première pierre de
l'opéra que le pari de 1962 a voulu
faire renaître et à 100 ans de distance
les crinolines ou redessiner les figures
du quadrille sur les airs d'offenbach
[Musique]
et
et route avec eux pour un soir à l'heure
française au casino du liban où le
festival de la chanson française tenait
ses assises et où un jury franco
libanais qui compte et marcel carné
avait à juger 70 chansons et quatorze
interprètes parmi lesquels l'usc en
plein jour là si la voiture se trouvait
là si la poussière de la base est
assurément sûrement pu faire
il ne pouvait pas partir la voiture et
leur écriture ils s'embrassent et
s'embrassent et puis des je t'aime
témoin au moci
j'applaudis illustra fut aussi celle que
le jury décide à de couronner doublement
du reste puisqu'elle est l'auteur de la
poussière audois grand prix de la
chanson qui lui valu le prix
d'interprétation féminine
[Musique]
le 13 novembre 61 à bien si twin une
gerbe de feu avaient jailli du puy
crachant vers le ciel plus de 600 tonnes
de poutrelles et de tubes incandescent
qu'ont dû dégager à grand peine
restez l'opération principale souffler
la flamme comme celle d'un briquet et
n'avait-on pas nommer la flamme des gars
it will le briquet du dia
2 800 mètres de profondeur on avait
réussi à amener grâce à des pompes
énorme le stock d'eau nécessaire à la
proche de la flamme
red adair le pompier du pétrole
avait constitué le stock de six mains
qui formeraient le bouchon destiné à
s'opposer à la fuite de gaz malgré son
énorme pression
et voici le jour j après de longues
hésitations red adair est allé dans son
bulldozer blindé faire une dernière
reconnaissance autour de la flamme et
diriger les derniers préparatifs
dans la nuit on a aménagé le fus 240 kg
de dynamite dont l'explosion doit
souffler la torche
le du soleil tout est prêt
[Musique]
l'opération soufflage commence sous les
tonnes d'eau déversées en lui par les
lances d'incendié la charge de dynamite
avance au bout d'un drap ferland de 10 m
transporté par un bulldozer cuirassé
d'amiante
[Musique]
et soudain c'est l'explosion
gagner la flamme brisées par le souffle
ne se rallument pas restait à juguler la
trempe de gaz ce qui a été fait
[Musique]
am seule la couronne de l'impératrice
eugénie la dernière couronne qu'une
femme et eu le privilège de porter en
france avec ses 13 154 drian ces 11 136
rose et ses 56 secondes suffirait à
faire voir 36 chandelles et plus à
celles qui viendront se pencher au
louvre sur dix siècles de joaillerie
française de charles le chauve à nos
jours se sont réunis pour un mois des
dizaines et des dizaines de milliards
d'anciens francs de pierres précieuses
et de joyaux au milieu des corps indre
royal dans l'une des plus belles et la
couronne de bohème la veuve demeure
parmi les pierres de la couronne de
france le célèbre réjean l'un des plus
précieux diamants du monde 137 carats
que marc il exauce laporta dans les
cheveux et napoléon au pommeau de l'épée
du sacre
on trouvera là également l'évangéliaire
de la sainte-chapelle le sceptre de
charles 5 et compte à côte or et
pierreries l'épée des rois de france et
la couronne de saint louis
[Musique]
autant de pièces de joaillerie qui
feront rêver sans doute mais qui
témoigneront aussi de la permanence à
paris d'un grand métier de luxe au cours
des siècles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]